okay it's uh it's 2 36.
um we we said that we would convene a
joint work session on division one and
division two uh or excuse me division
one and division three to uh talk about
HB 49
um HP 49 uh
started its life as a as a bill that was
intended
to
merely extend the the deadline for the
closure of the sununu center through the
end of the fiscal year and throw some
money at it HP 49 became overcome by
events as we passed sb1 as amended last
week
and so 49 has now become a vehicle
to essentially take what we did in sb1
that's now law the governor's already
signed it and then take the other
elements of sb1
um that has been worked on for a couple
of years now
and and and basically interleave it so
that by the time
SB 49 if if it passes with this
amendment it will have completed a
two-piece puzzle and we'll have we'll
have sb1
reincarnated
and sb1 as you may know was past 24 to
nothing by the Senate
and the the big Hang-Ups on getting it
passed in the last two years has been a
disagreement a principal disagreement
between
people over the capacity issue
the capacity issue has been put in the
parking lot and you'll see it in the
amendment
by an idea to have
decide evaluation that's already in law
and and in this amendment put into the
architectural designs
the idea of two scenarios two options
one option on the capacity is six to
twelve the other option on capacity is
an operational capacity of 12 with a
potential physical capacity of up to 18
to handle exigent reasons uh you know so
keep in mind
that it is not
the Department of Health and Human
Services who decides who goes to the
sununu center it's the judicial system
uh and so the DHHS receives the
requirement to um to detain these
individuals
from court orders and and then is
obligated to provide services so uh so
how many I need I know division three is
somewhat familiar with the whole sununu
Center issue but this is the first time
we've had division one here and I'm just
curious of the division one folks
how many of you are completely new to
the whole sununu Center where you don't
understand where you I don't mean to say
don't understand but but you haven't yet
had an opportunity to understand what
the community has been working on for
two years that this is kind of your
first blush at the idea representative
Sweeney
kind of a little I've obviously read up
on the dealings in the legislature that
have faced it but this would be my first
time on a committee task with the with
the center all right
um and I I I won't call you each out but
representative Griffin representative
evil well you're you're such a young guy
I figured you got time to heal if I
wound you so uh
representative evil your name's upside
down I don't know if that means you're
yeah
or have have either of you uh been had
cause to understand what the issues are
all right super and then uh
representative Cambray
um I I know about the issue but I don't
have the level of detail that I would
need to make decisions okay
representative Hewitt McGuire
representative Hewitt you probably have
sent kids there yeah right I'm I'm
familiar with the whole situation all
right yeah I've never visited the
existing Center so I I guess I don't
know exactly what's wrong with it it's
except that horrible things happened
there right we heard today from the
Judiciary there's a thousand cases
involved I mean on the um on the on the
uh a thousand court cases right yeah
well I we saw 640 earlier today but um
all right so
representative leishman when we talked
you you you said that maybe I should
chair this but I want you to feel like
you're co-chairing it do you have any
comments for us before we kick off
I'm fairly familiar with the situation I
have visited the facility so I have a
so
um
let's
let's address the first thing before we
get into the amendment itself I'm going
to ask Mr Ripple this is hot off the
presses uh from OLS so I've not really
had to look at it yet but let's have Mr
ribson come up
and you you've now got a sense of your
audience you know what we know you kind
of know what we don't know why don't why
don't you give us sort of the big
picture sweeping uh view of of of of
what's going on why over the last two
sure good afternoon everybody Joe ripsom
director dcyf
um I know that I passed these out a week
or so ago do does do folks still have
these would it be helpful to have a new
copy of these for anybody yes
just
um
for those of you who have these you'll
notice that the the color is getting
more faded
every time I print it I think we're
so again thank you thanks Kevin uh Joe
ripson director dcyf
um what you have in front of you is the
census data on the first page from sysc
so this is actually the daily census
every day from
July 2016 through the present
you'll see here right 2016 2017 you know
hitting 70 75 at a peak you do see a
major decline happening in like 2018
um that aligns with uh two things that
are happening one changes in law as to
who could be detained and committed at
the facility
and changes in a new emerging system of
care to be able to treat youth in other
settings in other ways and back in their
community so those two things are
happening at once and they result in
what I think is a a great story of our
ability to reduce the use of detention
and commitment for young people in New
Hampshire to a point where really other
than kind of this first you know six
months of 2020
we are
um always under 20.
the average daily census really for the
past almost three years has been 12 but
on any given day the census has been as
low as five and as high as 18. so those
are kind of your high water marks and
your low water marks but the average has
really stabilized around 12 during that
period
and I will pause for a minute to see
folks have questions about the sysc
census in particular before I move on to
the
representative McGuire thank you Mr
chairman so
um to me the the orange line Looks
relatively flat over this whole period
which means I guess that
um the crimes being committed is
relatively constant right and then
people are detained when they commit
such a crime yes yeah so the I I think
when I look at it to me actually it
looks like you have some pretty big
variation on both the orange and the
blue right even though they're you know
you're looking between
you know five or fewer up to you know 12
or so you know in terms of a percentage
of the total right you kind of have
variability of you know 50 in there on
any given day where you could have the
Orange Line being your detained kids you
know you could have less than five to
ten kids on a given day or we have had
at our Peaks here you know 12 13
detained kids on a given day that's the
Orange Line the blue line is your
committed kids and I think similarly
right where where you see you know that
number jumps up and down it's a little
more stable on the committed side than
the detained side and that's because
what I think a difference between the
way that the systems work for those
levels are a detained kid is typically
coming in
immediately after an incident law
enforcement arrests them there's some
immediate concern for Community safety
they're ordering that goes to a judge
judge orders detention a committed kid
is then after they go through that
process and the Court's making a
determination they committed whatever
offense that they're charged with
committing and that being committed to
sysc is the appropriate
um immediate result of that
so you know because the committed system
moves more slowly than the detained
system it's a little less volatile but I
both really I think do move around quite
a bit within that you know okay 30 to 12
range
go ahead thank you so so essentially but
to me the the committed line declined
until we hit 2020 and then it's
relatively flat similar to the detained
line all right and if you look at the
beginning of 2020 there was a peak of 25
on a particular day right because look
at what happened to the both the
committed and the detained lines they
both peaked in their little way correct
at the same day and that caused a peak
on the total right correct so but but I
don't see any particular pattern from
that point on until where we are today
over the next those three years right so
to me just because the two haven't
peaked together doesn't mean they can't
Peak together and therefore we can't hit
another 25. I think there's I think
that's that is a risk that that exists
you know when when you talk about
um you know the the size of the facility
moving forward I would say you know what
we've seen again for the past three
years is that we haven't crossed 18 but
for that period
um and you know things have kind of
been able to wash out in a way that
that's that's how it works but there is
always a risk right that you know if you
build something that it's not quite the
right size and I think that's one of the
reasons why you know we're a little
cautious about
um going much smaller than the data
suggests the current trending of data
suggests
representative who you have your mic on
do you have a question
I do thank you
um you're referencing 18
um is 18 the early January February 2020
timeline or was that one of the points
between July 20 2020 and now actually
the the time that we hit 18 New
Hampshire kids was actually in
I believe late January of this year so
that it was after the after this chart
shows oh okay thank you yep
so so because you you mentioned the risk
of under capacity would would you would
you tell us what the plan would be I
mean right now we have a much larger
facility right so there's probably some
room to maneuver in the 144 book bed you
know monstrosity we have over there but
if if we do get down to a smaller
capacity what do we do with any
additional
kids beyond that point yeah so you have
under current law the ability to use
what's called an administrative release
process for committed youth
um and I think I said this I don't
remember it was a division three hearing
of the full Committee hearing
um I have heard illegal interpretations
that suggest that we have that Authority
on the detained Youth too our own
attorneys have told us we don't have
that Authority for detained youth so we
don't exercise that Authority for
detained youth but for committed youth
there is a process for what's called
administrative release historically you
go back 10 15 20 years even before the
current sysc was built
um there were times where they had to
release because they reached fire code
capacity and they'd reduced the census
by using this so-called administrative
release process what we use it for today
is we look at the youth Who We Believe
who've been commit who are committed but
who have made the clinical progress
necessary to allow them to safely step
down either back to their Community or
to a lower intensity setting
and that's the process that we would use
to move kids out so
the only exit the only option that we
have really to to kind of address that
situation would be to use that
administrative release process currently
so if you were to exceed 18 that's the
process we'd have to look at which right
now is for committed youth at least
that's how it's exercise and how I've
been how it's been explained to me for
committed youth only
so so in the worst case scenario if you
have no
kids who are under a committed status
none of them can can be honestly
evaluated to have sufficiently passed
through the clinical phases of of the of
the interactions then what do you do
we'd be going back to court and begging
for Relief there's not really another
option what would that relief look like
for a judge to change their mind about
detaining a kid
okay all right and and then if you could
just lean into your microphone a little
bit
thanks all right are there any other
questions do you do you have more to say
I think about the history go ahead yep
so um again if we look at the next page
I'll be quick on this because it's not
so directly related to the senses of
sysc and I think I explained this last
time but the next page this is all of
the youth in the Juvenile Justice System
who are in residential care other than
sysa right so if they're if they're at a
facility a private residential facility
other than sysc and what I would say
about this what I think this story this
tells is that the system of care is
having an impact on youth entering the
juvenile justice system and having to
enter out of home care whether it's sysc
or residential and the reason I say that
is if the only thing that changed was
the laws around who could be committed
or detained I would have expected to see
those youth who were going to sysc show
up at a residential program at a
privatized residential program but
that's actually not what we see you do
see at the start of 2018 when the laws
first changed a bit of a jump of Youth
going into residential programs and then
you see a sustained decline over time
and what's really happening there is I
think told by the next page
so the next page is data on the flagship
program of our system of care
so our system of care for folks who
aren't particularly familiar with all of
this this is our children's Behavioral
Health System really started maybe
starting in its infancy seven or so
years ago but got a real Boost from from
the legislature from you know supportive
both parties support of the governor to
really build a robust children's
behavioral health system in this state
and their Flagship program is something
called a fast forward that's what we
call a high fidelity wrap-around program
where you have a care manager that care
manager is a clinical person they pull
together a team on a monthly basis to
work with the youth themselves the
parents anybody else who's important in
that kid's life so if they're involved
in Juvenile Justice their probation
officer would be there if they're
involved in child protection their child
protection worker would be there the
schools any treatment providers
everybody else and they work together to
try to plan around how do you keep this
kid safe stable and getting the care
they need within their home within their
Community within their school
um that's been I think a huge success
and has been kind of the driver behind
why we've seen at the same time the
reductions at sysc you've also seen
reductions in the residential system as
a whole if we flip back to the prior
page
I do just want to say that I am a little
bit cautious when I'm sharing this ad
about residential placements that when
you look at the kind of 2122 data I
think that is a little bit artificially
suppressed right now based on lack of
access because our residential programs
are not operating at full capacity
because of Workforce issues so I just I
don't want folks to get the impression
that this is kind of Recon this is the
new the new normal or the new status quo
it's probably underrepresentative of
need right now because again we have
access issues as a result of Workforce
issues
um so anyway that's kind of the big
story about what's been happening with
kids
um involved in the juvenile justice
system and
um ultimately ending up at sysc we also
have a few other really big efforts
going on
um that I'll I'll probably go into more
deeply when we have our budget hearing
in a week or so
um that I don't need to spend a whole
lot of time here but it does involve Us
Now using a formalized assessment
process whenever kids come into contact
with law enforcement and US using that
process to re-divert and direct kids at
that first moment of contact with law
enforcement instead of waiting for court
involvement to happen and through that
process we're seeing the majority of
kids who access that program close to 75
percent be diverted away from court in
the first instance so all of these
things do point to I think in the long
run we will likely continue to see
decreases but it's hard for me to
predict exactly what that is and I think
what um the one thing that I would like
to remind folks of I've said it here I
know in division three I'm not sure in
the others and I think I have copies of
the report here for people that want it
but that we according to a recent
National report already have the lowest
combined rate of detained and committed
kids in the country
so when we're looking at you know are
you talking about capacity for 18 or
capacity for 12 or capacity for six
there's not a whole lot of national
precedence for other states being able
to get a lot lower than we currently are
so I do you know I do want us to be
cautious and thoughtful about where we
currently are and uh where we think this
system is going to go representative
Waller has a question sure thank you
know for a long time I've been a
supporter of being sure that as few
children as possible are in this
facility
um
for a number of reasons I you know feel
that children do better when they're in
their own Community or not taken out of
their community
what other initiatives
have read through this
what other initiatives could we
include
in this piece of legislation it feels
like to me this piece of legislation is
lacking in that it does not include a
look at any other ways of reducing the
census there
um we've a couple of us have come to you
with some suggestions the last you know
couple of weeks and
um for whatever reasons those those
suggestions don't work I don't quite
understand why but they don't and I
would just like to know what else can we
do
to make sure that this census is as low
as we can get it yeah I think I think
there's a few things that are really
really important I think one thing
that's really important is continued
work on and support of the system of
care and actually having to be able to
reach full capacity and who it serves
right now it's not able to reach full
capacity for the same Workforce issues
that we have and there's a specific
program within the system of care called
Trek which is Transitional residential
enhanced care coordination but
essentially it's the same program as
fast forward is except for those youth
who are in out of home care who are in
residential programming or sysa we do
prioritize the sysc population for that
program right now but the same kids that
are in residential care across the state
are the same ones that ultimately often
end up at sysc because they have
challenges within their residential
programming and I think having that High
Fidelity wrap around available for them
is really really important having that
available throughout their full episode
of out of home care right now the
challenges with that are really around
Workforce issues right the inability to
hire enough clinicians to manage the
whole volume I do have a prioritized
needs request in the budget
coming forward that I'm sure division
three will look at when we meet next
week that includes a request for some
funding for localized Juvenile Diversion
programs when we look at the data
through the needs assessment process
that we're doing there's a couple places
where we're falling short in our ability
to connect young people to the services
they need that we think would keep them
out of the system those two places in
addition to Trek that I just talked
about are Juvenile Diversion programs so
a Juvenile Diversion programs do is that
they're local they're not funded by the
state right now they're funded
exclusively locally so you have some
communities who are who provide a lot of
support in this area you have other
parts of the state that don't and now
that we're doing an assessment and
recognizing that these kids have a need
for this type of intervention we're
finding gaps for kids to be able to
access that type of intervention and
what they do is they use a restorative
justice model to work with the young
people around understanding the harm
that they caused through their actions
working with victims to come up with a
plan for how to make that victim whole
so they feel like they've been heard and
supported and and you know come to a
resolution that that solves what their
issue is and then help prevent then they
help those young people implement the
plans to help make those victims whole
that's kind of the key piece of what a
juvenile diversion program does on top
of that they do some other kind of case
management connection work to support
young people that type of program works
really really well for a certain subset
of young people it's not this solution
for every young person right if you have
a young person with severe behavioral
health challenges that would qualify for
like a fast forward program a diversion
program might be a nice thing to have
but it's not going to solve their
underlying mental health issues the
other place we're having real real
challenges which I'm sure is not going
to be of any surprise to anybody is
access to individualized counseling
services or more of that outpatient
level care for Young Folks so when those
kids go through our assessment process
if they're not at a high enough level to
require say a fast forward intervention
that high moderate level intervention
but just need a counselor to speak to
right now we're having a very very hard
time accessing those Services Community
Mental Health Centers have very very
long wait lists for those Services a lot
of private providers have decided to
move into a private pay only space which
has made it really really difficult for
many of our families to to access that
so I think if you want to think about
and talk about how do we kind of keep
keep kids out of the system
we've actually built I think a really
Forward Thinking approach to identifying
those needs and driving those kids to
those needs but we're having some gaps
in actually Meeting those needs and
those are kind of the two key places
so what I'm wondering is are there any
children
presently
that uh come to the center that are sent
to the center that you think really
could
yeah that happens it happens sometimes
on a detained stat on a detained status
where they come in and sometimes a
committed status when they come in and
when that happens you know on the
committed status we use the
administrative release process to manage
that where we have a little bit of a
hold up right now is oftentimes in
accessing that residential care for step
down so if you have a child who isn't
maybe ready to go home but they don't
need to be in a secured setting our
residential programs are as I said
before really backed up right now in
terms of Workforce issues not operating
at full capacity on the detained side
you know that happens I think sometimes
where you know there's immediate crisis
an immediate issue and within 24 or 48
Hours the court revisits the decision
and then they release that young person
and we go into court and say hey here's
what's happening
um you know this young person seems like
they're stable the family's ready to
take them back and and that happens so
you know that happens currently through
the court process for kind of those kids
that have only a couple day Long
do you see any other
things we could do
in the law
prevent children from being committed or
detained
you know there's been efforts to look at
um you know what the what offenses are
eligible for detention and commitment
beyond the reductions that have already
been made and implemented into law
um I think it gets tricky you know there
was a there was a attempt to do that
last session and one of the things I was
worried about was that there was a
provision put into there to
um it was called like a Judicial
override or something and I was a little
bit worried that the application of that
might end up being a bigger exception
than the rule itself right so I think
it's we need to be really careful and
thoughtful about that to make sure that
it actually has the intended impact that
we're looking for and you know off the
top of my head I'm not quite sure how to
draw that line but you know I think
that's something that could be looked at
but is a very complicated process to
thank you
so oh
um
representative Hewitt just just to get a
feel for how the past is affecting the
present
uh to what extent do we do you have um
kids who are Court committed as a result
of a determination of a case the court
heard the case and committed the uh the
minor one of the one of the conditions
of that it used to be that uh the kid
got committed and turned 18 already went
but I understand that things have gotten
a lot better along those lines over the
years but to what extent do you now have
uh kids committed at the center uh as a
result of being adjudicated
so yeah I mean the so the data on
commitment right is it's the blue line
on here so a big part of this drop you
see is a reduction in the number of
Youth who are committed but it also is a
change in the length of stay that's the
other big thing you're seeing here so it
was common for youth to be committed for
the minority
um it's no longer common in fact the way
that the laws are written now for most
offenses they're eligible for parole
within three months and for more serious
offenses within six months and it's
pretty typical that they're paroled
within that time frame so the length of
stays are really really substantially
down from what they used to be so
typically within from I think if you
looked at the average committed youth it
comes out to be about three months that
they're there so that's it's it's a much
shorter stay where you do see the long
term at this point is kind of your they
fall into the detained population the
way that we categorize this and those
are for folks young folks who are
charged with very serious adult crimes
they're being held pending adjudication
of an adult crime
thankfully we don't see at least I in my
opinion kind of and overuse of that
exception I know right now I'm re I get
clips from around the country every
morning on Juvenile Justice Maryland's
having a big debate where they
hundreds and hundreds of kids a year
they charge for adult crimes
um when I've seen it here it's for very
very serious offenses like murder
attempted murder armed robbery it's not
for lower level crimes that then could
get a kid stuck in the system
indefinitely
representative uh oh
thank you chairman what is the
recidivism rate for those either going
out at the three-month window or the
sixth month window yeah
um so I don't have an exact rate but it
is higher than I'm comfortable with for
certain and I think that's true
um I think that's true for many many
Juvenile Justice programs around the
country the things that we've tried to
put into place to help deal with that
that aren't yet fully realized are
things like this Trek program that I was
talking about before
and trying to make sure that when these
kids get out they're tied in with an
intensive evidence-based community-based
program something like multi-systemic
therapy that we were able to stand up
about maybe two years ago but because of
Workforce issues they're only serving
maybe 30 kids at a time right now when
they're contracted to be able to serve
like 80 kids at a time so there's some
efforts that are in place to try to
really mitigate that but we are seeing
um you know a lot of those kids who go
out end up coming back
thank you
so so I want to just restate something I
think I've heard you say and and please
correct me if I've heard you wrong is
that um that New Hampshire should be
very proud of the fact that in the
entire nation on a per capita basis
we're either the lowest or second lowest
in the nation in terms of detaining or
committing juveniles so we're already
exceptionally low which sort of makes
one wonder you know how much lower can
we go with within the current law
we already have efforts to make sure
that we're only detaining the the kids
that need to be detained and that when
there's a potential committed kid who's
subject to a release that were
implementing those procedures and to
that extent of current law
the trend lines that you've shared with
us indicates
the success of those efforts already
under current law
under prospective law it's all Theory
with different schools of thought about
if a given change could increase or
decrease the number of committed kids we
don't know it's Theory
but we go back to the first point this
is the lowest state in the nation
already so the opportunity for
improvement
feels pretty limited that's that's my
takeaway from what you've said is that
fair or you disagree I I think that's
fair I I do want to say that I I still
do believe we can do better but I don't
think the way that in my opinion is the
way to operationalize that is not
through you know how many bedrooms you
build but through making sure that we
build a system that meets the needs of
kids rapidly quickly and prevents them
from getting down this path and I do
think you know some of the improvements
that I'm talking about are things you
might not realize for a number of years
right because it's those 10 year olds
today who are accessing the system of
Care at their first episode as opposed
to the 16 year olds today who are
already so deep in the system and
they're now accessing the system of care
so so we're we're about to start going
through the amendment unless there are
questions and I I I just want to make
again I want to just check in with you
to make sure I'm hearing you right is
that uh this amendment that we're going
to review still fully considers two
options a capacity of six to twelve the
other that has an operational plan for
12 people meaning you're going to staff
for 12 people
in other words we think we're going to
have 12 people but in the worst case
scenario we could go up to 18 if we
wanted to so we've got two plans 6 to 12
12 to 18. is there another range we
ought to be looking at some people think
we could just get rid of the sununu
center and rely on the system of care
what what what would you say to that
I
I don't think we have any evidence
nationally of that being a viable option
and since I've been here we've had a
number of young people who commit very
very serious offenses and we have
residential programs who aren't willing
and able to to serve this entire
capacity of young people so I think you
know I
I would love to see that day come but I
think banking on that happening right
now
um you know is it's a bit it's a bit too
much in the realm of what we'd love to
see and not and not what we are seeing
so under current law
we have set up the predicate that we're
going to continue to operate the current
facility in its in its current physical
state until there's a replacement
and so if we don't pass a replacement
they're going to end up forever in the
current facility is is that your
understanding of where we are now
currently that we're going to stay where
we're at maintain the status quo for for
as long as we can until we can open up a
replacement Center that will accept
these kids yes I think until and I think
until a decision is made about what
we're doing next that's that is the most
responsible way to deal with it okay and
and and so we're about to get into 49
but I I would like to add to those
points that this whole issue of delaying
a decision on the replacement Center is
is been pushing off in my view
the inevitable we we have to come up
with a replacement Center we can't come
up with no replacement Center the fact
that we have dawdled for two years has
decimated the the workforce at sununu
and as a result of Workforce reductions
they've not been able to begin their
shift over to a
trauma-informed therapeutic based model
they're still operating in a facility
that was designed for incarceration and
because their Workforce issues they have
not been able to transition to the kind
of the the the the the vision of care
that we see and because we've waited two
years the cost of construction it seems
to have gone up six million dollars
we thought it was going to cost 15 we
now have estimates of 21.6
so in the in the in in trying to do the
best for these kids I think we may have
hurt them by delay and I I hope that we
can work through this amendment and find
a way to move forward uh yes
representative Walnut well
don't want to bring this up but we are
the finance committee and I wondered is
there anyone here to talk to us about
the facility how much it's going to cost
when it's going to how long it's going
to take the Arc of funding all of that I
I invited Gophers gopher here
gopher was unable to send anybody but we
do have Ted kupper from Das here to
speak to the cost of the facility
okay
um you you can sit there or not because
you're probably going to be needed again
uh the gentleman from Das you're you're
welcome to join us
um
so the short answer is yes we have some
okay and I we tried to get gopher
because that's critical and and we will
continue to Endeavor to get gopher even
if it's uh ad hoc in one of our other
work sessions
so at this point gentlemen do you do you
do you both have a copy of the amendment
to HP 49 because because we're going to
start walking through that I see several
advocates in the audience do you all
have a copy of HP 49 with Amendment
okay
foreign
Vice chair thinks it would be a good
idea for you to introduce yourself for
the record at this point even though we
haven't asked you a question yet so
please do
thank you Mr chairman my name is
Theodore cupper I'm a professional
engineer and the director of the
division of Public Works designing
construction
uh in Under the Umbrella of the
Department of administrative services
were essentially a full-service
engineering and Architectural office
that either builds new buildings for the
state or maintains the one that they
already own
so so I don't know exactly what you do
but would you consider yourself a
subject matter expert on all the issues
related to design getting the process of
design done and making sure that we have
accurate cost estimates yes sir thank
you
okay with that represent representative
Mr Ripple would would you would you uh
March us through the amendment
sure and the amendment contains modified
language from
Senate Bill 1 as it came over from the
Senate
now just to refresh your memory on that
Senate Bill won as it was passed by the
house and signed by the governor just a
week or two ago did a few things it
removed
most of the text of Senate Bill 1 has
passed by the Senate and replaced it
with a few things it repealed the
closure date
the March 1st closure date for the
sooner Center it appropriated operating
funds for the rest of this fiscal year
it appropriated four hundred thousand
dollars for site selection and it set up
a committee or a commission rather to
evaluate site selection and make that
and other recommendations for future
legislation
this amendment does not
undo any of that but it does revive some
of the language from Senate bill one as
passed by the senate in modified form so
I'll walk through this briefly now
drawing special attention to the areas
where it differs from Senate bill one as
section one contains a statement of
findings and there is some new language
in there on lines 11 through 13 that
reads placement of children in
Correctional settings outside of the
state undermines the stabilization and
return to productive members to the
communities that is new and was not
section 2 requires HHS to construct a
replacement facility for the sununu
center The Language online 17 through 21
is new and states that the capacity of
the facility shall be determined by
demographic and other factors also new
on line 21 it states a smaller facility
of 6 to 12 residents shall be fully and
the remainder of the first page I
believe is the same as the bill that was
passed by the Senate
as you go on to page two
it talks about the design elements of
the facility that is largely the same as
the Senate passed version of house bill
one but there is some new language on
lines 13 and 14 again it states an
alternative plan shall be developed to
equally and fully evaluate a physical
and operational plan ranging from 6 to
12 beds in Residence
also new is the language online's 21-23
which states that operations May utilize
the programming and operational
requirements the start on line 24 is
largely the same as the Senate passed
version of Senate bill 1.
as is most of Page Three however there
is a difference down near the bottom of
page three Senate Bill 1 referenced a
completion date for the new facility of
November 1st 2024
this bill or this amendment removes that
date
and a few different in a few different
replaces and simply refers to an
accepted completion deadline for the
facility so it does not include a
Section 3 which begins on line 14 does
amend a small portion of Senate Bill 1
that was passed by the house signed by
the governor and has been codified into
law that required HHS to procure a
qualified architect on or before March
1st 2023 this changes that to within 60
days of the effective date of this
legislation
and on lines 20-21
it adds that the proposals for a
contractor shall be on a timeline
supporting the use of federal arpa funds
the final difference is in the
appropriation section that begins on
line 34 Senate Bill 1 as passed by the
Senate originally contained a 15 million
dollar appropriation this committee
heard from Das that the total cost of
design and construction would be in the
neighborhood of 21.6 million dollars so
this amendment makes that appropriation
instead
and on page five it emphasizes that arpa
funds shall be used first with any
so thank you for that
[Music]
um
I think in the version I wrote I
I said something oh wait so this is new
I think people need to see this on page
four
line eight through ten
we we had division three a lot of debate
on what the proper mechanism would be
for making an actual decision on which
you know on the site location and on the
uh
capacity and so lines 8 through 10
essentially charge the governor and
council with with using the information
from the commission and exercising their
discretion
so
is it do you think that's all the
changes
I believe so and you're right I had
marked up those lines as new and then I
skipped right over them uh
representative Mooney you have a
question thank you Mr chair I just want
to highlight on page two at the top
there this I think this is very
important and it needs to be said that
the name Will Change we're talking about
complete and overvamp of this for
various reasons but the name Will Change
taking off the word sununu and just
being known as the Youth Development
Center I think that's exceedingly
important as we move forward thank you
uh to that I I would actually be hoping
that a group of activists and community
members would spend some time in the
next year
identifying who what this thing should
be called I mean we've got plenty of
years to build this there's still an
opportunity to name it properly I think
the honorable Kim rice had suggested a
different name than YDC because that's
not very interesting so so I I think
there's time to actually come up with
the an appropriate name even
so
all right representative stream
and you know I might get crossed between
some of the Amendments that we were
working on uh before uh passing sb1a but
um uh what feels a little bit different
was you know at some point we were going
to have two complete architectural uh
layouts at 6 to 12 and 12 to 18. uh you
know where things would be compared and
costs and shared savings and so on uh
and um to me it feels a little bit
different that that the control of the
decision at that point is is strictly up
to the administration and and you know
it doesn't go back to the legislature
for a decision on which size of um of
new facility uh is the um
um the best one for our state okay okay
I may be wrong but I just want to throw
that no no no no no it's fair fair
observation I'll I'll address uh that
um if you look at first I'd say to your
point about whether or not we're
honoring the capacity
compromise that we made in the amendment
to sb1 this fully respects that capacity
compromise I think in two locations
you'll see that online
20 well first even before getting into
that keep in mind that sb1 is now
statute sb1 has has said that there
shall be two options for site evaluation
six to twelve and 12 to 18 right so now
we're talking past site evaluation and
into design and then in the build right
so the design part of it is on line 21
where it says a smaller facility a 6 to
12 residents shall be fully and equally
evaluated that's intended to to honor
the compromise
and then on page two lines 13 and 14
uh and an alternative plan shall be
developed equally and fully evaluate a
physical and operational plan ranging
from 6 to 12 beds in Residence so so
to your first point I think we've done
that that's in there
and then to your your second point which
I I take is
um
you know this this statute on
page where was I was just there
on page four lines eight through ten yes
it's I I try to draw people's attention
to that that is new now keep in mind the
legislature we we in division three
weren't able to come to any sort of
agreement we didn't even really make any
progress on talking about how how this
decision should be reviewed and made by
the legislature there was no proposal
verbally there's not been an amendment
put forward on how to do that and so uh
keeping in mind as I as I drafted the
amendment that I recognize that the
legislature has failed to make a
decision in over two years
that we needed to put this at a point
where a decision can be made and it'd be
accountable Now by saying the governor
you know the governor's obviously the
head of the executive branch and is
responsible for the dcyf mission but he
or she can't do it without the council
and the council represents an elected
representative body of the state so it's
not like it's being taken out of the
hands of the elected representative body
it just is Shifting which body because
this body has not been able to act
so
well under your leadership and and the
full committee I'm sure we can
I I hope is are there any comments
questions about
this amendment
so
so let's uh Mr I'm sorry is our hand oh
I'm sorry it's hard to see you down
there did you representative Hewitt did
you have a
oh representative McGuire did go ahead
my division knows how funny all right
anyways
um
in Senate bill one has passed there was
site evaluation right and it was going
to choose among several different places
is this premature in the sense that once
we know that the site is going to be X
that's going to affect the design and
other aspects yes
I I think it's a fair question I
wouldn't say it's premature I I'd say
that there's a tremendous amount of
detail in here to inform the site
evaluation team on what kind of facility
they they ought to be planning and and
and even if this were premature from
that standpoint I'd still say the timing
is necessary because the site evaluation
may not take place in the summer and as
you know the House and Senate are not
always in session so so we have to
decide while we're in session what we
shall do and and I think given that sb1
that had this kind of language in it
passed 24 to nothing and that the house
is probably divided on it that we the
timing is ripe I mean there's only so
many times we ought to be coming back to
the replacement question
what was the deadline in sb1 for the
site evaluation I don't remember I I
don't remember do you remember Mr Ripple
uh there was a September date for HHS
to to propose a site yes
and that was a not later then date
correct so so it could be as soon as
possible I mean Mr ripson I'll ask you
in just a second but but uh it's my
understanding that DHHS has a has the
contractor teed up and they know the
sites pretty well so what's your best
guess on on what reality is even though
you have till one September so we're
working very closely with my partner to
the left around
um
around you know entering into a contract
with somebody to do the site evaluation
work
um realistic timeline on that Ted I
don't
right now uh we've talked to a
consultant that we have a Statewide
agreement with they're going to deliver
a proposal to our office this Friday
and we're going to give them a notice to
proceed and we've asked them to complete
their site evaluation for us by the end
by the end of March that's pretty good
that's pretty quick okay is 400 000
enough or is it too way too much money
yes sir four hundred thousand is
adequate for that all right
and I have to all right so another
detail on page one line 16.
um so this document this amendment has
Department of Health and Human Services
shall be responsible to construct the
facility so with the assistance of Das
and I'm wondering if it maybe ought to
be backwards the other way around so
that it's Das who's responsible to
construct
with the assistance with the input from
HHS since Construction in general that's
das's bailiwick yes
you know I I I I I like what you're
saying okay I I would just um point out
two things if if you want to draft some
alternative language I I'd be very happy
to have everyone consider it
um but I would say that this language
has been vetted probably five times and
and you're the first brilliant person to
to figure out that it could be written
slightly differently I mean the Senate
passed that sentence that first sentence
24 to nothing did they not is that is
that the same sentence line 16 through
17 Mr Ripple
I believe it is yeah
I mean maybe these two gentlemen feel
like they work together like no problem
and therefore it's not an issue I don't
know what do you think
are you following the issue there Mr yes
sir is there a question yeah so the the
question is would it be would this be
better your responsibility to design and
construct this facility with input from
HHS as opposed to hhs's responsibility
to design and construct which is not
something they normally do I would think
right correct so uh normally the way we
proceed with capital projects
uh the division of Public Works is the
contract administrator we're in charge
of the contract to design and then
construct the facility
and the using agency is our partner
in that
so does that mean that the legislation
that creates those things writes it in
the opposite way to this bill generally
I would say normally that would be
opposite yes thank you
so again if if um if that sentence is
important to you let's let's get an
alternative language and look at it
because
all right representative Wilder I don't
consider the opposite way if you're
building a house you're building a house
you want to tell all the things you want
and then the contract is going to build
it with your input so you don't want to
take away the input yes they can build a
facility but
they want to deal with the people that
know what they want exactly in the
facility so
so Mr ribson Mr Cooper cupper cupper
um is there additional this description
provided in this amendment that would
facilitate the people doing the site
evaluation or is the kind of the
descriptive nature of this uh kind of
just irrelevant and and not really
needed for the site evaluation to to
um I think everything written here is
adequate to evaluate the sites that we
have before us and make a decision about
selection okay so does it is this
helpful in terms of informing the site
selection process to have this
in in statute or not necessarily
important to informing it it's just it
so I do think
having the direction of what the
expectation of the facility
to be is impactful on the site selection
process right so I do think that having
legislation in place that
that talks about you know things like
shared services as this does or that
talks about potential you know what do
you expect to have within your facility
because that then impacts the the
physical footprint and things like that
I think it's helpful to have that type
of clarity from the legislature to the
process that being said the legislation
that passed last time did talk about two
different options and we've you know
were able to move forward on that so I
guess it provides additional Clarity but
I don't think it's a prerequisite is how
I would put it
thank you are there uh representative
Abel evil
evil thank you Mr chair and um good to
see you Mr cupper we on public works we
saw him quite a bit
um I think we've talked a lot about site
evaluation and the effect that it might
have on the overall appropriation for
the construction and this does seek to
appropriate a specific amount could you
talk a little bit about how much the
site that's ultimately chosen can affect
the overall appropriation how much
variation you might see or anything you
could share with the committee to guide
it would be appreciated
uh thank you
um
I think the site selection
um is important from the operational
sense of the facility
um but it doesn't it doesn't do much for
uh the amount in the appropriation
um
the amount in the appropriation is going
to prepare a site but the but the
majority of the expenditure will be in
the design in the construction of the
building itself
and
typically the way engineering and
architecture work
we can design a building
off the ground anywhere in the United
States of America or the state of New
Hampshire and then we can place that
building on any site that you want it to
be placed on
operationally though as as Joe explained
um you know there are uh there are
perhaps operational advantages to being
co-located near facilities that can
prepare food
take care of laundry
um you know that sort of thing
so
um I think all of the sites there's
three sites that we're going to evaluate
uh
they're all adequate
what might change the appropriation is
if a site chooses to renovate a building
rather than build new construction
and at this point I have no information
available to me to determine what the
difference might be and the cost but I
would think that the appropriation of
21.6 million dollars would be able to
either renovate a building or construct
so so Mr cupper
um
would you do you know the history of how
we started at 15 million dollars in the
initial assessment and now we're at 21.6
and do you think 21.6 is the right
amount given that we have already
appropriated 400 000 for the site
selection process
so um you know just a little bit of
History uh when uh Health and Human
Services came to our division to talk
about this project
it was always about a 12 to 18 bed
facility that's the beginning of our
discussion
and essentially what that means is an 18
bed facility if if you're going to have
um additional capacity of six beds over
the 12 you're really designing an 18 bed
facility
so working with Health and Human
Services
um our our Architects
started to prepare out and flesh out
what a facility like that might need and
then start putting numbers to that and
um and for an 18 bed facility
uh it's it's always been a number of
about 21.6 million
um the 15 million that I understand came
from the availability of funds that
um in the in the very uh brief
discussions that I've had
um it seemed like 15 million was what
was available and could be provided for
the project I was asked at one point
what could we get for 15 million dollars
and I said we could have an adequate
facility to treat youth in the state of
New Hampshire I can't tell you how many
beds that would be until we get into the
design though but we could certainly
build a facility for 15 million dollars
would it be an 18 bed facility
absolutely not we don't think we can
build an 18-bed facility for 15 million
and that's where the 21.6 million came
from from our division based on
preliminary you know conceptual ideas
about what this facility
thank you representative Sweeney thank
you Mr chairman thank you both uh
questions for you director ripson on
page three lines 24-26 uh the Department
of Health and Human Services shall begin
to implement the programming changes uh
without regard to whether children are
at sysc or the new facility would that
require an additional appropriation for
your department to execute or will you
be able to no
um so the the changes that are really
discussed within the programming up here
are the types of kind of changes moving
towards a therapeutic model that we've
we've been working towards and hoping to
implement what's really become the the
barrier in implementation has been
stability of Workforce which has been
directly impacted by right the fact that
we had a closure date at least up until
last week of a week from now and um and
by other Workforce issues that that's
impacting all of our kind of residential
programs and everything around the state
so you kind of have those two things
that have made it impossible to move
forward with some of this programming in
the immediate term
um the the reason why it becomes
impossible in the immediate term was
because all of these kind of therapeutic
models anticipate that you're training
your Frontline milieu staff the ones who
interact with kids 24 7 365 on these new
models and when we have currently 17
youth count full-time youth counselors
where we need 45 ish you know you just
don't have the type of consistency and
Staffing to be able to implement those
programs so um so no there's not an
additional need for an appropriation but
I do think that you know getting Beyond
this point of not knowing what the
future is is helpful and I think the
other thing that's helpful is coming to
resolution around
um updating the standard job
descriptions and the salaries for the
folks who work at the facility and the
salary component of that's being
addressed in two different ways one
through enhancements that were approved
by the governor and Council last year
that would have to be continued and then
two through collective bargaining that's
currently happening in proposals around
increased wages Statewide and I'm
hopeful that the combination of those
two efforts would would get us to a
place where our salaries are competitive
enough to be able to fill positions and
having the clarity of future State and a
vision for where we're going would get
us kind of over this hump that we've
been in around kind of the you know is
the facility going to close is it not
going to close that really has been a
hampering our ability to hire and retain
staff so no I don't think we need
additional funding for that purpose
that's you know built in into the budget
request going into next fiscal year
anyway because it's always been the plan
for us to start to implement this work
but the the Practical reality of how and
when we do that is deeply impacted by
the stability of Workforce thank you
are there other questions
representative leishman thank you Mr
chairman
so I'm in a complete disadvantaged
compared to my colleagues on division
three so I'm going to ask you a couple
of specific questions uh
so looking at Senate bill one that we
amended and I believe it was unanimous
in this full committee which was a total
gutting of Senate bill one from the
Senate
and I've always had an opportunity to
read this through once and I've
underlined a number of things that I
think are an improvement to what we did
with Senate bill one is amended not to
put you on the spot but you're like the
expert so I like to do that
do you think this amendment is an
improvement would you agree with what I
S I think personally what I've read
again I'm at a disadvantage because my
colleagues on division three I've seen
this a lot more than I have this issue
yeah I I think that I think the
amendment looks really good right I
think the key components of the future
state that has been worked on deeply by
some members of the legislature by
members of of the advocacy community and
folks that work closely with kids and
families by our staff by a host of other
people the kind of key foundational
elements were all within sb1 I do think
there's some language changes in here
that help clarify and strengthen some of
those key elements so from that
perspective I you know I think there's I
think there's good stuff in here but I
think the the foundational core of what
we're trying to do with kids youth and
families within the state is really kind
of consistent between both thank you
appreciate it and would you like to
comment for a further questions I'd say
from an engineering perspective
um you know the budget that stated here
is probably more in line with an 18 bed
facility if that's what's chosen to be
built
um I might add that
um you know we we already have
interviewed and selected a consultant
that's going to help us design this new
facility
they're on hold right now we can't move
forward with their contract until
there's an appropriation for money to
begin that design work I think it's
important to note that
um
we saw the importance of uh you know
passing sb1 in one day unanimously
um as a message that uh we should work
as quickly as possible to get the site
evaluation done
so that perhaps the legislative session
would still be in session and be able to
appropriate money like this is doing so
that we wouldn't lose any more time than
we already have right now the consultant
that we've chosen
is revising their proposal for us and
and we're waiting for an appropriation
to bring it to governor and Council to
begin that work and they're looking at
the end of 2025 in their schedule to
have a new a newly constructed facility
if we were to be on the governor and
Council first meeting in May
thank you very much thank you Mr chewing
are there any other questions from the
committee
I go go ahead representative Wallner
Well I this is uh off the building for a
minute but
I think lines 21 to 23 aren't did you
say those are those are new they weren't
and I wondered if you could comment on
that are those new is that a new section
I I wrote that and I'll tell you where
that came from
um it reads operations May utilize
virtual and shared services when
consistent with the child's education or
treatment plan and appropriate to
effectively meet the needs of a
particular child or children
now the first version of it was really
just simple it just said Opera
operations May utilize virtual and
shared services but I was in children
and family law and one of The Advocates
found that particular sentence to be
really really important so I took the
language of an advocate and inserted
their language in there so that that's
that's that to me it didn't change the
concept to me it just clarified what was
already written and to me it was just
worth it to have the advocate here that
could you
I'm sorry I turned it off
um would you expand on
what the virtual and shared services are
what would you oh okay so for for let's
let's split them up virtual is basically
remote right you know we we know that
through telemedicine for example and so
I would think that uh I I would hope
that the operation plan that we get back
would take a look at leveraging uh
telemedicine tele-education capabilities
to help extend the emergency staff
that's at the clinic 24x7 so that you
could have maybe an LPN on staff instead
of a doctor
and that
um and that uh and that could work on on
education as well you know let's say you
get a kid with an IEP who needs some
specific you know Greek history from the
year thousand to fifteen hundred you
know then you could perhaps leverage
tele education to to bring those
services in that's the virtual component
the shared services component would be
if they co-located with a similar
facility the most valuable thing that
they could get from a shared services
agreement would be a clinical staff like
let's say for example they were at
Hampstead at Hampstead because they have
professionals on staff that deal with
juvenile cases then they could leverage
some of that staff between facilities
for decades now hospitals have entered
into shared services agreements on
simple things like laundry so laundry
could be another one warehousing and
Logistics could be another so you know
helping each other out on a dining room
support maybe yet another so I I didn't
get into the Weeds on what should be
shared and what should be virtualized
because I I believe that the folks
working on the operational budget ought
thanks
I have a couple more but
the people that I need to ask the
questions to are not here but they're
around the arpa funding
most of the arpa funding
I think almost all of the arpa funding
that we have allocated has come through
fiscal
and this is the I think the first time
I've seen it come as a budget item
it through a bill so I was wondering
about that and maybe that's a question
for the LBA and then the other question
I have is about the use of arpa funds
can arpa funds be used for Correctional
um institutions is that an appropriate
use all right Mr copper answer but keep
in mind the bulk of that appropriation
language passed 24 to nothing from the
Senate and and uh so it it isn't that
the language hasn't been vetted as as
this being an appropriate
vehicle but Mr cupper
I don't have any information for you on
that Mr chairman about the use of arpa
funds Mr Ripple did you get your
question in there that we we should
research I'm sorry what was the first
part of the question again
representative the first the first part
was really about whether or not
um we have brought any funding
through
legislation have we brought arpa funds
through legislation and then through the
budget or have we always been bringing
them off line through fiscal
there are bills that I believe have
passed that contained language similar
to this one appropriating arpa funds
first with any remainder coming from
General funds the bulk of Arbor funds
obviously have gone through fiscal I'd
have to take a look and see
which bills and what amounts have
appropriated arpa but I I think there
have been some
represent did you have a follow-up no
just just the question about whether
arpa funds can actually be used for
correctional facilities
that's a great specific question
representative Hewitt I I want to go
back to the uh the item on page two
pertain to operations uh the that
section is uh three the facility shall
be designed to include
and
each of the first h
items are things that are included in
the design of the building
I I don't understand
what the operations may include virtual
and shared services has much to do with
designing the facility
look well for example if you're going to
incorporate telemedicine into the clinic
space the clinic space would want to be
designed so that any sort of
telemedicine equipment would would be
within that for example you know not
just the physical space of the equipment
itself but making sure that the the
cabling like the the CAT5 or Cat6
whatever we're on these days is pulled
inadequate for the bandwidth did we just
leave representative Waller he said he
would stay until four
wait I hear you but I I still think that
uh
it's not con it's not consistent with
the with the uh with the design of the
paragraph it probably wouldn't cause
much of a problem but I think we need to
know that we're talking about uh the way
the the place is designed and not by how
the people inside the building are going
to operate once it has once it has been
opened so I I think we could entertain
alternative language and placement I I
think it's a fact bearing on the problem
and it's just an issue of of where it
okay so at this point
um
I see five people in the audience
um do you represent different advocacy
how many different groups are out there
five
okay is there anyone out there in the
audience who's seen this as opposed to
what we're doing
any any opposition in the crowd
is there anyone in favor of what we're
doing in the crowd I see one I see two I
see three I see four sir I can't see you
Mr ribson's too big
so so everyone in the crowd likes this
yay okay so division one would you
conduct a straw vote on whether we
should send this to
um finance and to the extent that
there's language that we ought to
consider we can consider in the full
finance committee representative Hewitt
has suggested he'd like to draft
something representative McGuire has
suggested he might want to draft
something so we I think we can take care
of those those are not big things
they're not concept issues they're
semantics
so my division one members any
particular position or I'm sorry
I guess representative yeah I just I
guess I've never seen a process like
this
um exactly I mean we bring in some
people who from across the hall who all
of a sudden show up and they really
don't have all the background and I
think probably the way we usually work
in division is that we have some time as
a division to kind of talk to each other
about what we're thinking and where
we're going
um and it just seems like an odd process
to me to be having two divisions taking
straw polls at this point
um I think you know there's a lot of new
information here
that we you know we for the first time
we talked about the building we talked
about the appropriation so I I just I
just think it's
it's a little premature to be jumping in
and taking straw polls but
so thank you for that feedback and since
division three has talked us to death
division one do you have a position on
that Mr chair
well like I said earlier with my
question
I personally am somewhat of a
disadvantage because I haven't had all
the information in the past I'm very
familiar with the issue of the sununu
center I do believe we need to move
forward we shouldn't be delaying this
um any longer and that's why I
specifically put my specific questions
to The Experts to get my reasoning for
you know hopefully moving something
forward if this if I saw folks in the
audience that were opposed that
represent that group of people that
we're here to re represent I'd be a
little hesitant so I I personally don't
have a problem with a straw poll of our
division one members
again we're not that familiar with the
topic but from what I've heard today
so that's my position Mr chairman
well thank you
um so do you want to conduct that straw
Poland
are the members willing to take a straw
poll I know this is a different way of
doing things but we're living in a
different
stage of the house being so close in
numbers
representative Kimbrell's
so what would you like me to say uh no
no
what I mean is based on what I've heard
here today I would feel comfortable with
moving forward and this is just moving
it forward to the full committee that's
not it's a recommendation if you will or
getting a sense of the division one
members I guess that's what the chair of
division three is apparently looking for
yes so I would feel comfortable moving
it forward to the full the full
committee
representative Hewitt
I'm likewise comfortable with moving
forward with it to see what the division
two has to say and make sure that we
have this this thing fully under control
you know I I've been suffering with this
issue for over 30 years and uh I think
is it a yes that moving forward to the
full committee oh yes we should move
forward get the whole committee on this
and as I said let's do it now
okay
represented Sweeney yeah I'm fine
getting the other third of the committee
uh in on this
um I'll just say for me personally I'm
not sure if it's ever been the case
where two options are given in
legislation for appropriation between 6
and 12 beds and 18 beds and the larger
isn't pursued
that's just my takeaway but I am happy
to hear the programmatic uh Pro parts of
the plan which I think are really The
crucial part are moving forward
regardless but I'm good sending it to
the whole committee representative
Griffin
yeah we need to move forward on the
sununu center solution
and uh
I've been through this pretty carefully
and I don't see anything in it it raises
a huge red flag
so I'd be comfortable with it going to
the full committee
I feel like uh like I'm really at a
disadvantage because I don't have as
much background as the folks on division
three I really would defer to them for
the ultimate decision I have
several questions about leaving the
responsibility to the executive Council
to make the final decision I have a
question about the Appropriations I have
questions about you know who should be
issuing rfps whether it should be Das or
DHHS I'm assuming all those questions
will be ferreted out and assuming all of
that on that basis I'm comfortable with
it moving forward that was a lot of
provisos but
I was like what was the very end I was
making notes here that was I said with
the understanding that several of these
issues are going to be ferreted out a
little bit more I I'm deferring to the
division I would be comfortable with it
moving forward thanks representative
hatched
microphone
I
given the fact that I just arrived an
absent of any new information given
today I'm not sure I I can give a
educated
vote so to speak I do trust my
colleagues on the convict on the
committee that are here and if it seems
like the consensus is to have it move
forward and this does need to be done
um so I can't abstain so I guess um
you know I certainly would support
moving forward Mr chairman so I think
it's
pretty close to a unanimous vote from
our recommendation from our division so
so the summarize that's that looks like
seven to nothing with the recommendation
to move it to the full finance committee
there are amendments that we need to
consider in the full finance committee
there are questions to be uh outstanding
the representative evil if if you could
if you could help Mr Ripple just make
sure he understands specifically what
questions you'd like to have addressed
in the full finance committee he's he's
really good at knocking those out so
okay and then
um
Mr clerk would you take a straw poll on
just ask everyone what they think and
whether or not they're willing to move
this HP 49 as amended by zero six two
I think I go last
so look I got everybody
um
representative Mooney
thank you just briefly I want to say yes
I am in favor of moving this forward to
make that clear uh secondly I just want
to thank Mr ripson and Mr cupper for all
of your information and your patience
through this process those of us on
division three have heard from you now
multiple times and you've always
answered sometimes the same question and
we truly appreciate all the time you've
dedicated to this thirdly I just want to
make a mention that there's a great
cross-section in the audience I notice
and based on a straw poll you've all
nodded your heads as yes I think that's
very telling so let's move forward thank
I would move it forward but I would like
to hear the answers to a few of the
questions that we still do not have
we've still not had a chance to meet
with arpa and I think that it's not arpa
I guess it's gopher
um I think that that's kind of an
important piece of this
um I don't want to find us a year or two
down the road and all of a sudden find
us in a situation where the feds have
something that they would like to tell
us so
representative tolerski
with respect to the committee I missed
almost an hour of discussion on this
amendment and so I know it won't make a
difference but I'm just going to say no
on the principle of that that I have not
heard enough of the discussion of
specifics on the amendment
General
thank you
um
I know there's an open request to go
visit the current sun in New Center I
think there's real value to the members
especially me being a Freshman on this
committee and dealing with this issue
for the first time so I I would my
preference would be to retain it until
we've had that discussion and that visit
so for now we're recording you as a no
you're not ready you're not ready to
move it to the full financing correct
representative
no
okay
um representative nordgren is not here
um
uh I would say no Stringham
uh votes no and I think that just leaves
so I have three yeses
and four nose and Two Notch here so on
the basis of today's vote I'm going to
move this uh hb4 as amended to the full
okay
um are there any other questions or
all right
uh last call Representative Weiler or
excuse me you're not Weiler you're the
other one walner we do look alike I know
um
okay
how was it you just decided you were
going to move it forward when didn't
division how did division three uh
division yeah how did division three
come out
I I uh I took the seven
plus the three that's uh in this
combined joint committee that's a ten to
four
and we have representative Weiler who
I'm sure would have voted yes we had
representative Maguire who committed to
me before this meeting he voted I've got
to be here to vote so so but the the
straw count is uh is is ten to four and
I'm just really sick of this bill so let
let the let the full finance committee
deal with it I'm done we're done we've
done this it's dead we've done this
yeah
so when it goes to the full finance
committee usually it gets exact pretty
good and there's not an in-depth or time
for in-depth discussions around the bill
so
um moving this forward to the full
committee is it the intention to have it
exact time in the near future or what
what is the intention I will not speak
for the chairman of Finance I I I'm
moving it back to his domain with a
recommendation of uh Joint Committee of
uh of ten to four
to move it to his committee we we've
also picked up a number of questions and
potential amendments that the full
finance committee ought to look at so if
I were him I would still think that
we've got a few things to discuss and
consider it's not quite ready for exec
in my view but I don't want to speak for
him
representative thank you for my own
process since I'm new is this comment
that we would have multiple divisions
come and take a vote on something before
moving it
so that's a good question and I've been
told that these work sessions are very
flexible and
um and and and uh and I just applied the
flexibility with the permission of the
chairman and with the chairman of
division one and uh you know we just
took a straw vote
10 people would like to get the full
finance committee involved and get it
out of division three that's all this
representative hole thank you I want to
change your vote by any chance
um
so I want to concur with your last
statement this may be somewhat weird but
in my understanding is via the clerk
right the various divisions are truly
subcommittees as opposed to distinct
committees like we would think about
children family law versus I don't know
um criminal justice
so because of that right the bill always
kind of resides with the full committee
and the subcommittee did some work to
figure out what the what the potholes
are and we've discovered some and we
need to work on those and but really the
subcommittee really can't do anything
other than make a recommendation like a
subcommittee would on any other
committee and ultimately the
jurisdiction of the bill is the full
committee um I think representative or
chairman Edwards sought out other people
um to kind of work on this but I I think
there's there's still some work to do on
the bill and I think that's going to be
a long day in in finance
that's what we roll our sleeves up it
took it was a long day on sb1 it will be
a long day on this one I'm sure as well
so I would just point out when we had a
very long day on division three and came
out to a very specific uh agreement on
what we would move forward it was 15
minutes before bringing it up that I was
told that people's minds had changed and
uh I you know I I not being able to
trust the people who like don't really
trust the process I'm ready to move this
to the full finance committee